culture chefs really good as human
beings in drawing lines in the sand how
many people here by show of hands have
reconnected with somebody that they had
not talked to in five years because of
Facebook raise them don't get lazy
please stand don't lie if you said the
following to yourself ever in your life
please raise your hand I'm not getting a
Facebook account why in the world what I
need a Facebook account how about 10
years let's really think about this
lying is the devil please don't be lazy
on me you're leaving after this look at
that almost everybody you're not gonna
want to stand for this one but I need
you to do this for me how many people in
this room don't [ __ ] lie
stand up how many people said this doozy
I will never get a facebook account
please raise your hand right now stand
if you do not have a Facebook account
don't you holy [ __ ] I've down sorry give
me one second one oh I see it
I see you nice work I have no idea why
the [ __ ] you seven people are here I'm
not getting a [ __ ] cell phone how
many of you said I will never get a cell
phone
why would I want anybody to contact me
anytime they want please raise your hand
holy [ __ ] you tell the truth wait
holiday no twelve do you want a mobile
phone are your parents here what if I
bought you a mobile phone good thing I
don't work it out fight it guys 70% of
this room don't be lazy if you said that
to yourself raise them higher has
reconnected with another human being I'm
gonna wait a second because I know
there's a couple of you bullshitting
don't sit down yet that they had not
talked to in over 20 years because of
the growth of social media please stand
up a lie how many people in this room
love Pinot Grigio raise your hand don't
be scared please do me a favor
suave soo a ve at the price don't buy
the bola suave in a big bottle don't be
cheap like the eight to twelve dollar
suave from Italy 2010 vintage really
strong you'll stop drinking the PG horse
[ __ ] okay
we as human beings
love to draw lines in the sand we hear
new [ __ ] and we say we're not going to
do that and sorry about the person